ANDREW TOY: All right.
Little bit loud.
Hi, everyone.
We're going to get started now.
I'm aware that people are
still coming in from lunch,
but I think that's OK.
My name is Andrew Toy.
I am a product director within
the Android and Chrome team,
and I'm here to
talk to you today
about how we see
devices and the cloud
coming together to help
build the connected workspace
of the future.
How we see the devices
adding to the cloud,
and the cloud capabilities
being additive to our devices
strategy.
Obviously, with Google we have
Android and we have Chrome OS.
So those are our platforms,
and we definitely
build those to be cloud
oriented, but most
of what I talk about
today is basically a way
that you can look at a general
devices strategy plugging back
into the cloud.
So many of you will
already know this.
These are statistics that
we all see flying by,
but there's a lot of
confusion and there's
a lot of progress going around
how we use devices today
in the workplace.
Many, many people,
everyone here I'm sure,
are using their devices
everyday for work,
but what does that really mean
in the context of extending
the workplace?
And we all know that IoT,
the Internet of Things,
a very heavily overused word,
but the Internet of Things
is coming.
Those are also devices, and how
do those plug into the cloud
and plug into a general
mobility strategy.
So the way that we
see it at Google
is that while we've all talked
about mobile for a while,
mobility really is more
about the next generation
of modern end point,
and the next generation
of modern device
that is connecting
to our centralized data
systems within a company.
Now that could be
in a data center
and that could be in a cloud.
We think that that's moving all
towards the cloud, obviously,
but it doesn't have
to be the cloud.
But we definitely see device
proliferation increasing
the amount of data
that is actually
going into all of our
systems, the amount
of data that could
be available to us
as people who operate
within companies,
increasing the amount of
data that's available to us
as application developers.
And bringing all
of this together
is really where
we see the future
of application development
in a mobile first world.
And the next generation
of that is just
being an internet
everywhere world.
So the way I like
to think about this,
and this is a
slightly different way
of looking at the
mobile problem,
a slightly different way of
looking at the devices problem,
is that really what
we all want is data.
Data is what is valuable
to all of our businesses.
to application developers.
And the reason we do all
of this stuff around mobile
is actually to proliferate data.
To sort of it's available
to us all the time,
and then we feel like
we can take action
upon that data in any
place, at any given moment.
So that's the traditional
knowledge worker definition,
where you have say your email.
And one of the very first
use cases for mobility
was extending email out so we
could have email everywhere.
Because email is that
most generic way that we
can deliver information, right?
So if you get a sales report,
it can be emailed to you.
If you approve say
a expense, that
could be done,
theoretically, over email.
So what made email
special was that it's
a very general
transport that allows
lots of different kinds
of data to be sent
to us as individuals, and that
was very enticing and very
appealing.
But the extension
of this is that we
want all businesses to become
data centric businesses.
For business decisions to
be made around the data,
and to make it be
generally more available.
We hear from a lot of customers
that this is absolutely
what they want, and we
see devices and mobility
being as essential in
actually achieving this goal.
But let's take it
up another level
and say well, why
do we want data?
We don't want data for the sake
of just having stuff, right?
More stuff is not what we
actually want in our day
to day lives.
But what we believe here at
Google is that you cannot
improve what you cannot measure.
So measurement is actually
really, really important.
And it's obvious, and we
all know this at some level.
But it's something
that's very easy
to lose sight of unless you
really bake it into your day
to day thinking.
And for us, it's
baked into the way
we think about our
entire mobility strategy.
So the first stage is,
how do we measure things
within our environment?
We can be measuring
productivity,
we can be measuring individual
output of employees.
And that's one part of it.
But we could be measuring
spaces, measuring
how spaces are used, measuring
collaboration, measuring
manufacturing within a factory.
We want to make sure that we
have insights and actually can
gather information
in all the places
that it is available to us.
So an example that
I'd like to give
is thinking about getting
access to an experience
that many of us have.
An experience with say you
go to a fast food restaurant.
I go to fast food
restaurants more
that I generally
like to admit, but I
go to fast food restaurants.
So you go there.
A lot of fast food
restaurants here in the US
will actually know
how much they actually
sell to the people who
come to their stores.
It's something that
they will know, right?
So they know that they sell
x number of hamburgers,
or x number of
tacos, or whatever
it is that they're selling.
And they'll know that because
they have their point of sale
in their store.
So they have data.
And they can optimize
on that data,
and they do, and they
can make projections,
they can deal with supply
chain, and they can do
all those things on that data.
But many of these
stores actually
do not know how many people
come into their store.
All they know is
how much they sell.
That's all they know, how
much they sell because it's
in the point of sale.
They don't actually know how
many people come in the door.
So if you ask what the
conversion rate of is
for someone coming
in the door, it's
actually very hard
to tell because you
don't know what's going on.
You don't know when you
sold one taco whether or not
that one taco was sold
to one individual who
came in, or did a family of
six come in and order one taco.
That information is invisible
to the actual company.
So instrumentation is actually
a slightly less obvious thing.
It's obvious you want to
instrument your sales,
but it might be slightly
less obvious to instrument.
Well how many people are
coming into the store?
How many people are
parking in my parking lot,
and do they all
come into my store?
How many, when they
come into my store,
are they all ordering and then
taking it back out to the car,
or are they ordering it and
then sitting down at a table
and eating it there?
These are all actually important
operational fields for someone
to run their restaurant,
but a lot of businesses
are blind to this data today.
So I deliberately
give that example
because it's probably an
experience we all have,
but not something we're
thinking about every day.
And instrumentation,
and this word
we have of just gathering this
information of all the data
that's important to your
business is the first step.
The second step is
analyzing that data.
So first of all, we get the data
and then we analyze the data.
So the analysis stages.
First of all, you need
to put the data somewhere
which is useful and common, and
you need to put in clean data.
And second of all, you then
need to sort of pull out
insights from that.
We with Google are
very good at this.
Google Cloud is
very good at this,
and we have many tools,
ranging all the way
from just query tools like
BigQuery to store the data
and pull stuff out, over to
machine learning, that can
actually help optimize fields.
And I'm sure many of you have
heard about those capabilities,
but that's the phase that
we're talking about, analysis.
And finally,
there's improvement.
Which is we don't do
all this unless we
want to improve, right?
Business outcomes.
We want to increase
revenue, we want
to increase the
number of people who
come to a store,
the number of people
who order the actual products in
the store, or buy in the store.
And that's the improvement.
And then you go and do it again.
You don't go through a cycle
where you just say well,
we improved it, let's move on.
You improve it, you measure
it again, you improve it,
you measure it again.
Very simple concepts, but
fundamental to how we can
actually do this better now.
Much, much better
with a combination
of devices and the cloud.
So the idea is that by
using our fleet of devices,
we can actually put very cost
effective instrumentation
within any number of workplaces.
If you want to know how
your conference rooms are
being used within your offices,
that can be easily measured.
If you want to
know, that examples
I gave before, how a
restaurant is operating,
that can be measured.
If you want to know how
a hospital is operating
and how the patients
are interacting,
that can be measured.
Many, many things that were kind
of difficult to measure before,
or were measured
ad hoc, are now be
able to be measured
in a much cleaner way.
And that data, it can
actually stream up and be
placed in a central place.
So if you imagine
for a moment that you
operate many, many
restaurants across the US.
I'll just stick with this
example, quick service.
And you have all
your franchisees,
you have all this data,
imagine that you suddenly had
access to all this rich data.
Like the number of people
coming in, the number of people
going through the drive
through, the number of people
using your parking lot,
the number of people
ordering the products,
using the tables.
Like how every employee is
actually performing on a day
to day basis, how many
things that they're making.
All of this data
has to go somewhere.
And that place is actually going
to be in the cloud, definitely.
It doesn't make
sense for businesses
to build out all their
own data systems,
absorb all this new data
that they now have access to.
The cloud is where
it's going to go.
And as Google, obviously
we have every component
of this particular story.
We have great devices
between Android and Chrome
and our Internet of
Things sensors platforms.
We have the GCP, the
Google Cloud Platform
to absorb all that data
and provide analysis.
We have layers on top of it
to provide productivity tools,
and general analysis
tools in G Suite,
and a lot of different
applications,
just cloud applications
across the portfolio.
Like Google Maps, for example.
That could be used to
garnish the data that's
being pulled in.
So the place that we see this
going, from a connected work
spaces portfolio standpoint,
is that first of all, we
want to make sure everything
is going to be connected.
Everything is going
to be connected.
So every device, every
mobile platform, every sensor
should be thought
holistically and together.
You should have one thing for
running your email, saying well
how am I going to
do BYOD with email?
This way.
Then how am I going to do
my corporate liable fleet
for document management?
OK, this way.
Then how am I going to
do IoT smart sensors?
This way.
These are all
actually end points,
and all devices are going to
be connected to the internet.
You can add the security
stuff on top of that,
and I'll talk about
it in a moment,
but they're all going
to be connected devices.
Maybe not tomorrow,
but definitely
within three to five years,
everything we will all be doing
will be connected.
And so the idea
we have is we want
to lay the foundations
right now of our strategies
to be able to accommodate that
future massive proliferation
of devices.
You want everything to be smart.
And when we say smart, that
means that data centric point
of view.
So think about where your
data is being gathered.
Think about how to secure that
data, how to move it around.
Where you're going to build your
repositories and your caches.
Are you going to actually
gather that data, for example,
at the individual
store level and then
move it up to the cloud?
Are you going to
have every device
stream that data straight
into your central data
centers within the cloud so that
you can actually individually
have those use APIs?
All those decisions
are the ones you want
to be thinking about right now.
And we'll talk about
security in a moment.
So this is the sort of
easy way to break down
the phases when we're
talking to customers,
and the way we're thinking
about it her as Google.
The first stage is think
about how to better instrument
your business.
Giving your employees devices to
get their email have documents
was the first stage
of instrumentation.
That's what all our
companies were actually
doing when we actually
give out those devices
that like interact with work
and interactive work data
work applications.
We are instrumenting
the employees.
The next thing is you
want to instrument
probably, [INAUDIBLE] on the
bottom, the spaces, right?
So areas like this
room, for example.
So we know how many
people are in the room,
we know which of the people
in this room are Googlers
and which people
are from outside.
Instrumenting your spaces
could be from retail spaces
to hospitals, anywhere
with brick and mortar,
conferences, conference
room space, micro kitchens.
All those kinds of things
is where IoT comes in.
And that's where
a lot of that data
is going to be coming in
over the next few years.
Another area that people
don't often think about
is instrumenting the
customers as well.
How are you going
to actually get data
from your customer base?
And BYOD, and
applications, and mobility
can actually feature
into this, as well as
plugging into the devices they
have within their environments.
So you know when Amazon
gives out devices
so that you can order
from Amazon at home,
that is a way you can
instrument your customer base.
And all of these data
streams should not
be thought of as separate.
And that's what we have
all the little interweaving
of the actual streams there.
All of this is going
to come together.
And you want to think about how
you actually join and analyze
all this information in a way
where you can easily gather it
with the instrumentation phase,
and then run queries upon it,
and gain insights in
that red analysis phase.
And that's really where
the cloud comes in
because it's all too
easy for individual silos
and individual groups
within the enterprise
to be thinking about this.
And you end up storing all
your data at individual silos,
and really, that's just
not what you want to do.
To get real insights,
you want to be
able to join this data to pull
out really cool information.
And that's where machine
learning comes in as well.
The more siloed data
there is, the harder
it is for you to
eventually use something
like ML to pull out insights.
And to be future proof,
you want to be thinking
about your data warehousing
strategy, your device strategy
right now.
So connected devices, and
we talked about this before,
are absolutely going
to just be everywhere.
That's just the world
we're going to live in.
And you know, I'm a mobile guy.
I've been in mobile
for a long time.
I've been mobile all the
way back to the days when
we're using WAP on phones,
in case anyone ever did
WAP programming.
We all carry the certain
scars that you carry if you're
coming from those days.
But I've been in mobile
for a very long time,
and mobile was
defined for a while
to be like, well first
of all telephony.
Then it was telephony with
tiny, tiny little bits of data
using something like WAP
in carrier walled gardens.
Then it was, OK
now mobile is OK,
we're going to just
start to put the web
and put the internet
on our devices.
Then the iPhone came
and said well no,
these are tiny little
computers, and then
mobile really means how do I
develop apps for this new place
because we were just
put to go to all web,
and now we have to develop apps
for Android, and for iPhones,
and things like that, and
put them in the app stores.
Mobile now, I think actually
just means everything.
Everything is going
to be a mobile device.
Don't even think about as a
separate category anymore.
Just think about your devices
and endpoint strategy.
Don't think about what's
my mobile strategy,
and what's my other
strategy, right?
I used to say this, and I think
we're actually right here now,
but when I gave a talk maybe
two, three years ago, what
I used to say was
I know it feels
like mobile is its own thing.
I know you feel
like you're going
to have your own mobile group,
your own mobile application
group, you're going to
hire mobile developers,
it feel like its own
separate category.
But trust me, mobile,
a few years ago,
mobile is just going to
be like the term internet.
So in the late 90s, the exact
same thing was happening.
You had your internet group,
you had your internet experts,
you hired internet programmers.
And it was like wow, there's
this whole internet category
that a business
would have and say we
need to have an internet group.
And now very, very few companies
have an internet group anymore.
The internet is actually
just built all the way
through the culture
of the company.
It's built all the way
through every strategy
the company makes.
You don't just say well, yeah.
How do we deal with, the
internet guys will handle that.
It just sounds outmoded.
That's where we immanently
are with mobile right now.
Again, it's we're
just on the cusp.
You might intuitively
feel that way,
but you will feel
that way very soon.
So I encourage
everyone in this room
to stop thinking about mobile
being a separate thing,
mobile is now fundamental and
as existential to every process
that you do.
It is existential to every
business's ability to compete.
When you think about
something to be mobile first,
even that is a phrase that
we're kind of moving away from.
Mobile just needs to
be in the conversation.
It's just like an endpoint
discussion, a device
discussion.
And we feel we were seeing this
as well on the devices side.
So when people
come and say well,
how are we going to
build a mobile app?
The first thing I say is, well,
what do you mean by mobile?
What exactly is mobile?
Where does mobile end and
where does laptop begin,
or convertible begin, or
tablet begin, or phablet begin?
Or are you saying that
tablet is part of mobile?
And there's actually not a
consistent definition for that.
Sometimes it's
like, oh well, it's
based on screen size
and all these things.
But really, that doesn't
really make sense
because maybe if you have
a great application written
for your phone, and you
want to blow it up so
it runs on this
screen right here.
Does that mean it's
not mobile anymore?
Even though it's an
Android application.
That doesn't really
make sense, right?
So what we're seeing
at Google, and this
is from our Chrome OS and
our Android strategies,
is that we really just think now
about capabilities of devices.
This is how you want
to use this device,
and how appropriate is this
device for this particular use
case?
And when you think
about it that way,
then everything
becomes a continuum.
You shouldn't have
a separate security
story for your small
devices, your IP devices,
and have a simple security
story for your signage
or super secure use story for
your actual knowledge worker
laptops.
Everything should be
on the same principles.
And it's just certain
properties of the device.
Like whether it has its own
separate soldier connection,
whether or not it needs
to run local applications,
or does it just run
web applications?
These are just orthogonal
things you decide as you come up
with your mobile strategy.
So this is a good
example of that.
People might notice already,
but about a year ago,
I think, maybe a little
less, we announced
that Android applications
were coming to Chrome OS.
So previously on Chrome
OS, you could only
run things through Chrome like
the web, HTML5 applications.
Makes absolute sense, right?
It's called Chrome OS.
But now what we decided to do
was say well, you know what?
Sometimes it makes for you to
have some local information,
to have some local data.
So we're going to take
the secure paradigm
we have on Chrome OS.
We're going to add
to it the ability
to deploy applications
via Google Play,
and let any Android
application run that device.
And what that means is that
as Chrome OS moves and says,
well, it's not in a
laptop form factor,
but now it's in a
convertible form factor.
You can take off that screen
from the Chrome OS device,
run it as a tablet, and have
full access to all the Android
applications in
the Play Store that
are optimized for tablet and for
mobile and just have them run.
Because now that
Chrome OS device
is literally an Android device.
It's not emulated,
it's not pixel pushed,
it's not simulated.
Chrome OS devices
are Android devices,
even when they come in large
17 inch laptop form factors.
So that's what I mean by that
blurring where at some point,
rather than trying to
reconcile this model of
is that a mobile
device, or should I
use my mobile security story
for that, or my laptop security
story?
It's actually better
just to revamp
the way you think about
your endpoints and that way
you think about your
development to actually just
encompass and embrace
this choice that we have,
versus forcing yourself
into like knots.
Trying to pigeon hole things.
Which is what I see a
lot of people doing.
And we're trying
to help with this.
We're trying to help
with this by bringing
this modern way of
doing application
management, this modern
way of doing security,
and building it into all of our
device endpoints by default.
You'll see this in Android,
you'll see this it Chrome.
So everything we have
here is available on both
those platforms.
Getting comment management
APIs so you can always
feel like you're in
control of your data
and in control of
your endpoints.
And bringing those across all
of the endpoints we work on.
And we'll always
prioritize that.
And like I said,
you can actually,
many of the people using other
end points, Windows devices,
Mac OS devices, you'll
see that same thing
happening across the board.
But we at Google
definitely believe in it.
And of course, we see
cloud native people.
Cloud native application
usage requires the cloud,
and so the security story
and the application of story
extends across, not
just the endpoints,
but all the way back
into the cloud as well.
So when we say
well, how do we make
sure that the applications you
develop for mobile or now run
on all of these
different devices,
the cloud is an integral
part of that story.
We're no longer
living in the world
where you're going to do
virus scanning locally,
and then have local firewalls,
and have local malware
detection, all these things.
You're going to have modern
endpoints with strict security
policies, manageable
by it from the cloud,
and the cloud will actually add
to the security capabilities
of those endpoints as well.
And so the two
will work together
because we're going towards
this always connected world.
And so yes, we'll always
think about how things
work in an offline
scenario, but we
want to optimize
it, take advantage
of the incredible
power we get by having
the cloud available to
endpoints and devices.
So we think about this
as a general solution,
a general platform.
At Google we think very broad.
But we see the applicability
of this approach
into individual
verticals as well.
And we've listed some here.
And if folks are in
from specific verticals,
please do ask questions, or
come up at the end and we
can talk about specific
verticals and how it applies.
But these ideas is that
the connected version
of all these businesses are all
actually relatively similar.
They all follow the theme of
saying what information do
we have in these environments?
Remember that
instrumentation phase.
How do we instrument
these businesses?
What are the key
things that people
wish they knew,
or wish they could
tweak as performance attributes
that they have never had access
to?
And how does the
connection on proliferation
of devices that are
connected to the cloud
enable us to actually
measure and improve
those things, where we were
never able to do that before?
And not only are we
able to do it now,
but do it in a very
quick and rapid fashion
that allows for iteration and
rapid business value delivery.
So a few examples here, and I'll
go through them quite quickly,
Coca-Cola is actually
thinking about putting,
and actually is putting
connected end caps.
Basically, those things at
the end of the supermarket
aisle where you go there
and it has some Coke bottles
and things.
The smart connected
versions of those
rolling out to
stores nationwide.
Where there's a smart screen
combined with smart sensors
and beaconing to actually have
customers go and say wow, yeah,
you know what, I want
to engage with this,
I want to look at
this stuff, I will
help make a selection from
what product they want to do.
And we're seeing that
not only does that
improve Coke sales,
that actually
improves overall beverage
sales in that particular store.
Not just from the ones from
that particular end cap.
Rentokil has an example
of coming up pretty soon,
is using machine learning to
actually help in pest detection
and pest control.
And [INAUDIBLE]-- that was
discussed in the keynote,
it's actually instrumenting and
upgrading their manufacturing
plants by using Android
and Chrome devices.
So at this point, to
talk more about this
and focus on business
transformation,
I'd like to invite
up Nisha Sharma.
She's at managing director
at our partner Accenture.
NISHA SHARMA: Thank you, Andrew.
Thanks so much.
Hi everybody.
My name is Nisha Sharma,
managing director at Accenture.
First of all, just wanted to
thank you for inviting me here
today, and also want
to wish all of you
a happy International
Women's Day.
So thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Yes, so I've been at Accenture
for about 18 years now.
And for the past 13,
14 years my focus
has been in enterprise mobility.
And enterprise mobility,
what we really mean by that,
is how do we help our
workers, our employees
with mobile solutions?
How do we make them
more productive, more
effective in the
work that they do,
and how do we provide them
with new technology to do that?
And I think right now we're at a
really, really interesting time
because we have a lot
of innovation to bring.
And to me, as a
technologist, as someone
who's really passionate
about all this stuff,
it's a super exciting time.
And we're doing some really
cool things with our clients
that are really changing
the way that they do work.
So I wanted to maybe
just spend a little bit
of time on where we are when it
comes to enterprise mobility.
And I actually say we're in
our third phase of mobility.
And what I mean by that is,
when we first started out,
when we were talking
about mobility 1.0,
this was really just getting
devices out to our workers,
and they were pretty
simple devices.
It was typically a corporate
liable environment.
We're giving them the devices.
And you really,
all you were doing
was email, calendar, very
basic stuff like that, right?
Maybe those were the
old BlackBerry days
when we were doing
that kind of stuff.
Then we shifted to
mobility 2.0, which
is really more about
transactional applications.
Now we're starting to do more
simple things with our devices.
Not just email, but now
we're actually maybe
we're doing some
dashboarding, or we're
getting some basic time and
expense type of applications,
or we're able to
order things, or we're
able to just do
simple transactions.
Things that we used to do
on our laptops or desktops
were now able to do
some of those things
on our mobile devices.
We also started, this
was the days of BYOD,
we're still in those
days of course,
but it was about
bringing your own device
and not necessarily
the corporate liable
locked down devices.
But how do we allow
you as an employee
to use your own device
for work purposes as well?
But now where we are
is in mobility 3.0,
which I really see as our
transformational phase.
Now we're actually
trying to transform
the way that we do work.
So it's not just
taking what you used
to do again on your
laptop or desktop
and put it on a smaller
device, but now we're
actually trying to change
the way that we actually
do a business function.
And we've got some
examples, and I'll
show you some things of
what we're doing there.
But this is really where
the cloud story comes in,
which Andrew was talking about.
Because a lot of these
capabilities that we need,
all the personalization,
the contextual awareness,
all of that is using
the cloud to help us
with those types of solutions.
So I wanted to just kind of
talk a little bit about what's
happening in the area
of mobility again.
Some would some would
say that, well, I
think enterprise
mobility is actually
becoming less about
mobility and more
about these holistic
anywhere, anyhow, experiences.
And so some people actually
say that the term mobile apps
is now an outdated one
because maybe now they're
digital apps, or maybe
their digital experiences,
or maybe they're just apps,
whatever we want to call it.
But we're moving away
from mobile apps.
And why is that?
It's because I think the mobile
device itself is changing.
Typically, or traditionally
we've thought of mobile devices
as being phones
or tablets, right?
That's what we typically
classified it as.
But now, we've got
wearables, whether it's
your watches or
your smart glasses
or whatever it may be, your
car is now mobile, it's running
Android, it's got all
this capability in there,
refrigerators, toothbrushes,
I mean all sorts of devices.
Everything is now
a mobile device
and we're treating it that way.
So the device has
definitely changed.
The way we're interacting,
as well, is also changing.
Typically when you have
a mobile application,
you're tapping on it,
you're selecting drop downs,
you're entering
some text and forms,
I mean it's that kind
of an application.
But now we're using chat, we're
using messaging communications,
we're using voice
more now actually,
we're speaking
into the phone now
for some of our
applications, Instant Apps.
We've got Android
Instant Apps as well,
that are changing the way
that we're interacting.
So that is all changing.
And then we've got these
new intermediaries.
So ways that we're now
connecting and talking
to our employees
and our customers
is changing in ways that
we didn't have before.
If I look at all the
transactions that actually
happen through WhatsApp, or
all the transactions that
are happening through
Facebook Messenger,
or now with Google Home,
or Google Assistant,
think of how we're actually
connecting and talking
to these devices to interact
with our back end systems.
So this is something
that's really
changing again the
mobile applications
to now digital applications
and digital experiences.
So there's a few trends
here and where we're going.
I think we've already
talked about device
and app usage will
continue to rise.
I think this sat around
70% of our workers
today are already
mobile workers.
That number will keep
growing, especially
as we go to the
rest of the world.
And then the apps, the app
usage, it also is increasing.
So companies are building
more applications.
And not only are they
building more applications,
but they're providing
access to those applications
to more and more users
within the organization.
If you think about
before, maybe it
were like pockets of
employees within a company
that were actually using
mobile apps and mobile devices.
But now we're opening it up.
We're looking at
HR applications,
finance applications,
marketing applications,
and so on and so on.
Beyond what we
traditionally thought of.
Enterprises are going
to keep increasing
the spending when it comes
to mobile applications
and mobile devices.
As more and more users
are starting to use it,
they need more applications
or new applications,
and the ability to provide
those solutions to those users
so they will continue to
invest for the next few years
in this space as well.
I think now, like I
mentioned, I think
we're seeing a need
for innovation.
There has to be innovation
in all that our companies do.
We, at Accenture say that every
business is a digital business,
and you know whoops,
I went too far.
But companies need to innovate.
Whether you're a company that
is leading in your industry,
you need to innovate to kind of
keep ahead of your competition.
Or whether you're maybe a little
bit behind in your industry,
but you need innovation
to stay alive, right?
Because your business may
not exist if you don't keep
innovating and keep
doing new things.
So there is definitely
a need for innovation.
Deep handset functionalities.
When I saw this one, I thought
it made a lot of sense.
Because if you think about
how we use mobile applications
today, we typically
just use the screen
when you think about
it for work purposes.
You use the screen, you're maybe
inputting into an application,
you're tapping here
and there or whatever.
But we don't use the camera.
We don't use all the sensors
that are on the device.
I mean, our hardware
partners keep
adding more and more
features into the devices,
but we don't really use them.
And I think that's
really starting
to change now with some
of the new capabilities
and new functions
that we have, which
I'll show you some examples of.
And then, as I said,
the mobile experiences
would continue to
evolve as we have
new ways of interacting
and new experiences
that we're looking to
provide to our workers.
So last fall, we announced
our partnership with Google.
It really is all about
providing enterprise solutions
to our customers,
to our clients,
and it is all based on built
on top of the Google technology
stack.
You know, I started working
with Andrew and his team,
and really looking at
how do we bring Android
into the enterprise, and there
are definitely differentiators
with Android when it comes to
the wide variety of devices
out there.
The form factors,
the price points.
There's a number of
really strong reasons
for picking Android.
But one of the things we
said is that the real value
is the entire Google
technology stack.
There is so much
there that we can
bring to life through
Android applications,
and that's what we're trying to
show with some of the solutions
and capabilities that we have.
So I wanted to show you and talk
to you a little bit about what
are some of these
innovations that we're
seeing with our
clients, and what
are some of the interesting
things that we're doing.
And I'll hit a few of them.
So collaboration is
one of those areas.
You might not think
of collaboration
as being so innovative.
I mean we've been using
email, we've been using chat,
we've been using all of
these things for some time.
But what's not really there is
how do we actually incorporate
that into our workflows?
Like most of us, we're probably
on email all day, all the time,
right?
It's just there.
It's one of the apps
we're constantly checking.
But if you think of
like a store worker,
they're not checking
email all the time.
Or if you think of someone
on a manufacturing plant,
they're not checking
email all the time.
But that's a great
tool that they
can use for various purposes.
Even the integration with
calendar, the integration
with Hangouts, or the
chat capabilities,
being able to talk to people.
I mean again, we may all be
on our computers all the time
and just chatting with
people whenever we need to,
but it's not so common in
the rest of the enterprise
in the workforce.
And the integration with
Drive as an example.
So if I'm like a
salesperson, I don't
want to go and search
somewhere for a document
on a particular
product or something.
I just want to be able to
go to my product catalog.
I want to see what
that products are.
And if I want more information
about that product,
I want it to be right there.
And so we can integrate that.
We can integrate
all of these things
into our mobile applications
to provide a better experience
for workers, and something
that they're actually
going to use day to day.
Digital assistance.
This is a really fun one.
So have you heard of chat bots?
Maybe some of you have
heard of chat bots?
We're seeing a lot of really
cool examples of using
chat bots on the consumer side,
as well as the enterprise side.
So you know today, when
you're maybe booking a flight,
or you're calling
customer service,
you could use the chat
function that's there,
like let's say on a
website or something,
but that's usually a human being
on the other side of that who's
actually responding to you.
But now we're
getting to the point
where it doesn't have
to be a human being.
It's just a bot.
It's something that,
it's a machine that's
responding to you.
And we've done a few
different examples
in rollouts of chat
bots for a call center
type of applications.
But what we've actually
built out as well,
are a chat bot for
workers, for employees.
So we've got one as an
example for a field worker.
So a field technician
who might go out
in the field to fix something
or to work on something.
Well maybe they might
come to a situation
that they don't
know how to solve.
And the worst case, as you
may know in field service
is, to have to say you know
what, I can't fix this.
I'm going to have to
send somebody else out.
That's like the worst
situation that a field service
company would want to be in.
So we want to make these workers
productive, and self-sufficient
while they're out there.
So we gave them
the ability to just
say, hey Google, why is this
transformer not working?
And then it's using
machine learning
to suggest things for you
to try to troubleshoot
that particular item.
So that's a great
example of how we
can use chat bots for workers.
We have another one
for a sales worker,
where this one is a little
bit more intelligent.
This one is more like
your personal assistant.
So whereas a field
worker was more of a hey,
help me troubleshoot this, the
sales worker application chat
bot, which we called
Donna, Donna, is--
you can just imagine
you, as a salesperson,
are going to your client, "Hey
Donna, tell me about my day."
And she'll actually speak
out and say, "You've
got four meetings today.
Your first meeting is
with blah blah blah."
"Hey Donna, tell me
who are my hot leads?"
And she can tell you these
are your hot leads in the area
that you're going to today.
Then she can get even smarter
and say, I can ask her,
"Hey Donna, what products should
I recommend to this customer
today?"
And she can actually take
a look at all the things
that are happening
around this customer.
She can take a look at what
their past purchase history has
been, what their
inventory levels might be,
what their contract statuses
might be, and actually
suggest things for
you, as a salesperson,
to go and talk to
that client about.
So it's about, again
using machine learning
to make these
personal assistants,
or chat bots there
as your helper.
Image recognition.
So this is a fun one.
I'll actually show you
a demo of this one.
Today, this morning
there was actually
a press release about the work
that we just did with Rentokil.
Rentokil is a pest
control company,
and what they wanted
to do was, they
wanted to equip their field
technicians with the ability
to take a picture of insects,
cockroaches, beetles,
whatever it is, and be able
to automatically identify
what it is.
Their technicians
are great, they're
used to all sorts of bugs,
but they come across bugs
that they don't necessarily
know or sometimes we'll
get it wrong.
And that could have a
big impact because it's
really important for them
to know what type of bug
it is so that they can provide
the right chemical treatment
and chemical mixes to treat it.
So that's what we did.
So we actually
built an application
that allows them to take
a picture of the bug
and it will identify it.
So if I can switch here,
I'll actually show you.
I don't have any live
cockroaches here with me,
but I do have a
couple of pictures
and I'll show you
how that works.
Can I cast it?
There we go.
So this is the application.
So I'm just going to
come and identify a pest.
So you can see here I've got
this lovely cockroach here,
and I will take a picture
of this cockroach,
and I will use it.
And now again,
it's using machine
learning to calculate and figure
out which type of bug this is.
And we've trained it on a
number of different cockroaches,
and beetles, and
so on, and so on.
And it identified that this
is the American cockroach,
and that's what my
cheat sheet says here.
It is the American cockroach
that I actually just scanned.
So it allows you to do that,
it allows the technician
to see that picture
and actually compare,
and say yup, that's
the right one,
and it will provide them
some detail with it.
All right, we go ahead
and select the match,
then it's going to
populate the information
in the application about
that particular bug
or that treatment.
Today they spend
a lot of time just
manually going in and
having to fill this all out,
now we've just automated it.
And if I keep going then
it's going to provide me
with a session summary.
And what it does is, this
place was a pretty nasty place
I guess, pretty infested
with all sorts of things.
But now I can go and
view a remediation plan.
So because it identified that
this is the American cockroach,
it will tell me how to treat
it, what I should be doing,
and actually will also provide
recommendations for a customer
so that they can help to prevent
this from happening again
in the future.
So that's an
example of how we're
using machine learning for
pest control, which I never
thought I would do.
But yes, that's an example.
We can go back to
the screen please.
Another example of using machine
learning for image recognition
is what we did with our
smart parking application.
So we've got this implemented
in a few different places today.
But if you think about
your experience when you go
and park in a garage, for
example, parking garage
or a parking lot,
you might go and it
might say that there
are 50 available spots.
And it's calculating that based
on sensors that are actually
in every single parking spot.
That can be very expensive
to first of all implement,
but also to maintain
in an ongoing manner.
So what we did was we
actually trained the models
to identify empty spots
versus occupied spots.
So this is using
cameras, camera imagery.
Many, many parking garage
and parking lots already
have CCTV cameras
and other cameras
already in place like that, so
we can pull from those images
and just be able to detect
empty spot, occupied spot.
Somebody's perhaps parked in
illegal parking spot where
they shouldn't be parking,
and those notifications
can go to the right
people to deal with that.
But now, as a consumer,
or as an employee perhaps
is looking in coming
to work in the morning,
as I come into the parking
area, it can send me on my app,
hey, your parking spot is here.
Because you can now
reserve a parking spot.
You go park in there
and it just allows you
to direct the parking that way.
So a really interesting use
case of how, again, we can use
machine learning for parking.
OK, so the last example I have
here is augmented reality.
This is a really fun one.
I think this is
where Google really
shines because they've got
some cool technologies, which
I don't think any
other companies do.
So one example here
is the far left there.
This was again for
a field worker.
So the idea is that, as a
field worker, if I'm going out
and I come across
an object again,
I'm maybe not familiar
with it, or maybe it's new,
or maybe I need to
learn how to do this,
I can either use
my smart glasses
or I can even use a phone,
and I can use the phone
and just kind of hold
it up to that object,
so this is a water pump, so I
can hold it up to the object,
and it will provide
some overlays to me
and tell me check this
transmitter level,
check this valve.
It will guide me,
and show arrows,
and point to where I
should be looking at,
and help me to troubleshoot
that particular water pump,
as an example.
We did another one.
This screenshot here
is with the Tango,
if you're familiar
with our Project Tango.
This one we-- these screen shots
are from what we did with BMW.
And they are now actually
rolling this application out
to their showrooms
and allowing people
to come in and virtualize a BMW
car in their environment, which
is a really cool.
And I can show you that as well.
But what I wanted to show you
was an enterprise use case
of using Project Tango.
So if you're not
familiar, Project Tango
is more of an augmented
reality type of scenario.
We've also got some virtual
reality demos and solutions
as well.
Virtual reality is more when you
know you've got your head set
and you're everything you're
seeing is in your virtual world
there.
But augmented reality is
actually using your real world
and applying some additional
information or virtual objects
within that, your real world.
So think of this scenario.
As a salesperson, I
go out to my client,
and I go talk to him
about the products
that I'm trying to sell.
Well typically, I would
bring those products with me.
Well, what happens if I'm in
a industry where the products
that we make are too big,
and they're just too heavy,
and I cannot physically bring
them with me to the meeting?
So now that's where
we've got to this example
here on Project Tango.
So if I can head back to
the Chromecast, please.
I need to switch devices.
All right.
So I'm just going
to load this app up.
So simple name, augmented
reality catalog, ARCAT.
Now what this is
going to do is, it's
going to allow me to
virtualize an actual object
in my environment.
So if you look here, there's
no big drills or anything.
So what I can do, is I
can select this object,
and I'm going to
drop it right here.
So now you see this object.
This is the actual
size of the object.
I can go around it, I can
take a closer look at it,
I can even go inside
it, if I wanted to,
and actually see what's going
on in that particular drill bit.
And then I can
manipulate it, I can
get some additional
information about it.
So it's a great example of how
I can bring this object here.
Now imagine if it's something
bigger like this big bit.
This is the actual
size of this thing.
So I've actually put it
here in my environment.
Again, I can walk around it.
I can take a look at all the
different pieces of this thing.
I can see what this, get
as close as I want to
for this thing.
I can even go
inside, if I wanted
to see what's in it for
those types of use cases.
So again, a great
example of how I can
bring this technology
to my client.
But now what if I want to
show how it actually works?
So I can do simulations,
if I can place it here.
OK, so this is the drill bit.
And it's actually showing me how
it works because it's actually
drilling into the ground.
Now this device, it recognizes
and understands the space
that you're in.
So it can figure out
that this is the floor,
those are the walls, that's
the ceiling up there.
But this is the actual
size of this drill bit.
And you can see, if I can
bring this to my customers,
it will really show
them how it all works
and what the actual
experience is like.
So if we can go back
to the screen, please.
So those are some
examples of innovation
and what we're actually
doing with customers today.
And at this point I'll
invite Andrew back up,
and take it from there.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW TOY: Thank
you very much, Nisha.
Those were wonderful demos.
Thank you for not doing
the insect demo live.
Thank you very much.
We appreciate you
spending time here.